the solar system our home in space we
live in a peaceful part of the Milky Way
our home is the solar system a four and
a half billion year old formation that
races around the galactic center at two
hundred thousand kilometers per hour and
circles it once every two hundred and
fifty million years our star the Sun is
at the center of the solar system
it's orbited by eight planets
trillions of asteroids and comets and a
few dwarf planets the eight planets are
divided into four planets like ours
Mercury Venus Earth and Mars and four
gas giants Jupiter Saturn Uranus and
Neptune mercury is the smallest and
lightest of all the planets a mercury
year is shorter than a mercury day which
leads to enormous fluctuations in
temperature mercury does not have an
atmosphere or a moon venus is one of the
brightest objects in the solar system
and by far the hottest planet with
atmospheric pressure that is 92 times
higher than on earth
an out-of-control greenhouse effect
means that Venus never cools below 437
degrees Celsius Venus also doesn't have
a moon earth is our home and the only
planet with temperatures that are
moderate enough to allow for a surplus
of liquid water furthermore it's so far
the only place where life is known to
exist the earth has one moon
[Music]
Mars is the second smallest planet in
the solar system and hardly massive
enough to keep a very thin atmosphere
hmm it's olympus mons is the largest
mountain in the solar system more than
three times as high as Mount Everest
Mars has two small moons Jupiter is the
largest and most massive planet in the
Solar System it consists largely of
hydrogen and helium and is the theater
for the largest and most powerful storm
as we know its largest storm the Great
Red Spot is three times as large as
Earth jupiter has 67 moons Saturn is the
second largest planet and possesses the
smallest density of all the planets if
you had a sufficiently large bathtub
Saturn would swim in it Saturn is also
known for its extended very visible ring
system it has 62 moons Uranus is the
third largest planet and one of the
coldest of all the gas giants it's also
the smallest the special thing about
Uranus is that its axis of rotation is
tilted sideways in contrast to the seven
other planets it has 27 moons Neptune is
the last planet in the solar system and
is similar to Uranus it's so far removed
from the Sun that a Neptune near its 164
earth years long for the highest wind
speed ever measured was in a storm on
Neptune at just under 2,000 100
kilometers per hour
Neptune has 14 moons if we compare the
sizes of the planets the differences
between them become even clearer Jupiter
is the leader in terms of size and
weight small mercury on the other hand
is even smaller than one of Jupiter's
moons Ganymede Jupiter is so massive
that alone it contains roughly 70% of
the mass of all the other planets and
has a massive impact on its surroundings
that's a blessing for Earth since
Jupiter draws most of the dangerously
large asteroids that could wipe out life
on Earth but even Jupiter is a dwarf in
comparison to our star the Sun calling
it massive does not do justice to the
Sun it makes up ninety-nine point eight
six percent of the mass in our solar
system for the most part it consists of
hydrogen and helium only less than 2% is
made up of heavy elements like oxygen or
iron at its core the Sun fuses 620
million tons of hydrogen each second and
generates enough energy to satisfy
mankind's needs for years but not only
the eight planets orbit our Sun
trillions of asteroids and comets also
circle it most of them are concentrated
into two belts the asteroid belt between
Mars and Jupiter and the Kuiper belt at
the edge of the solar system these belts
are home to countless objects some as
large as a dust particle others the size
of dwarf planets the most well known
object in the asteroid belt is Sarris
the most well known objects in the
Kuiper belt are Pluto Makemake
and her mayor usually we describe the
asteroid belt as a dense collection of
bodies that constantly collide
but in fact the asteroids are
distributed across an area that is so
indescribably large that it's even
difficult to see two asteroids at once
despite the billions of objects in them
the asteroid belts are fairly empty
places and nonetheless there are
collisions over and over again the mass
of both belts is also unimpressive the
asteroid belt has a little less than 4%
of our moon's mask and the Kuiper belt
is only between one twenty-fifth and
1/10 of Earth's mass one day the solar
system will cease to exist
the Sun will die and Mercury Venus and
maybe earth 2 will be destroyed in 500
million years it will become hotter and
hotter until at some point it will melt
Earth's crust then the Sun will grow and
grow and either swallow earth or at
least turn it into a sea of lava when it
has burnt up all its fueled and lost
most of its mess it will shrink to a
white dwarf and burn gently for a few
billion more years before it goes out
entirely then at the latest life in the
solar system will no longer be possible
the Milky Way will not even notice it a
small part of it in one of its arms will
become just a tiny bit darker and
mankind will cease to exist or leave the
solar system in search of a new home
[Music]
you